right good morning everybody good
morning
everybody in the at the meeting there at
the plans committee the 12th of Janet
good morning to those who may be
watching on the courage
um
today is apologies perhaps
yes Chad apologies Council a lot
counselor Watson Council of Pennington
substituting pencil and wise men
councilor bushby substituting thank you
Chandler
at item two on the agenda of the minutes
of the meeting held on the 1st of
December on pages 5 to 16 and I'll move
those from the chair yeah did I just
raise page six and the other
applications I'm not listed I've been at
the virtual recycling they did go on to
the site visits to look at them prior to
the meeting I wanted the good report at
least yeah can you record that Shannon
that councilor Pennington we did see the
virtual Senate visits also in your
Motion in the past the rest of the chair
thank you Council Pennington uh can we
vote some of those minutes please
thank you
that's about 10 you're not here again no
that's the brand
councilor Bush B so councilor Christie
councilor craigie oh cancel the 11.
councilor Pennington four
about six foot and when I'm standing
chair thank you
item three on the agenda is Declarations
of Interest
um I know everybody knows this off by
their heart now but for those in the
room who are visiting us this morning
and the girls on YouTube members with
interest to declare should refer to the
agenda
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
considered
elected members of General County
Council and Terror and Parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
Council hold a person of interest and
are deemed to have considered the
application separate there and the
express views of that council do not
bind the level of concern we'll consider
the application of fresh
and I always say it's at this meeting
where we get all the latest updates and
information on applications
which not necessarily to determine the
Polish councils
okay I need some for his agreements of
agenda between Parts one and two there
is no part two
item five are Urgent matters
foreign
[Music]
six is public participation
and I shall have to go back in a minute
for introductions I must thank you
that public participation without prior
requests to speak uh for the first night
item which is
um there's a letter to be read out from
the applicant Tim Hooper
the West Village on the first
application with Robert Hort who's
speaking against his speaker mail for
the parish council or his Parish Council
we've also got Richard ains Ainsley
against the member of the public
we've got
Ben Harris his autorussia interested
and we've also got councilor hero who's
the ward member who called the
application in who's speaking and on the
second application at West
chandsworthy again and we've got Robert
Hall speaking against he's a parish
councilor
uh Richard Ansley again a member of the
public speaking against that
Ben Harris the applicant speaking in
support and again councilor heckles here
the speaker's award member
it's expected that all the retainment
plans committed that they'll give a fair
uninterrupted hearing to the planning
officer giving their report and to all
those listed to speak and to the
planning committee members when they
begin their considerations
after all it's only common courtesy
thank you and the Order of speakers is
his problems the planning officer will
give that presentation of the
application and then any town or Parish
Council
representatively wishes to speak four
against the application have three
minutes
and then two members of the public who
want to speak against the application
now it's three minutes each
and then two members of the public in
support of an application they have
three minutes each and then at the end
any tourist district council member from
the Ward Emirates application Falls and
there's no time limit on that Ward
number but without them to be reasonably
and then after that the plans committee
then debate the application
with with any questions in our very
appropriate officer
right so we'll move on then to item
seven well before that I'll do what I
should have done at the start which is
get the committee and the office is
present to introduce themselves I'll
start up in the cell councilor Chris
leather and I represent Northern and
then I'll move over to Pastor Douglas
being I'm the chair of orange but I'm
here uh representing
um
vegetable water
and your award is the difference
good morning my name is Peter Christie I
represent Biddeford North as well
the only rural member I was wondering
today
hi Andrew principalities
good morning my name is Devon Golf and I
representative North
okay and on my left then we're gonna
domain manager yeah I'm Helen Smith
planning manager
Stacey Dory head of legal governance
good morning Matthew Environmental
Protection Officer
good morning my name is Sarah Boyle and
I'm the development management team
leader
and the two most important monsoon
Brown Democratic Services officer
everyone in Sandra Democratic Services
of us so thank you okay right now we can
get on with the actual applications the
first one this morning is 7A and then
Sarah will take so we'll take this up
again thank you chair so yes the
application zero eight four five twenty
twenty two is for the erection of an
ancillary Annex at 120 Cavalli road
bideford so this was subject to a
virtual site visit and I'll run through
the slides now for you so this is just
to show the location of the site so as I
said it's on 120 Valley Road in rear
Garden it is in the development boundary
of bideford
um it is surrounded by residential
dwellings and to the kind of north east
and south and into the West immediately
there is a car park that's already there
this is just the show a brief kind of
existing psych plan of the sites of that
kind of entails the 120 Club Valley Road
the next door neighbor which is 121 and
then Montague Place to the north
it's just a satellite image
um of the the site
um so you can see the car park there's
the West on the new place and then the
house fronts onto 120 Crivelli Road and
the gardener is in behind
foreign
so this is the entrance
um looking at 120 Valley Road
um kind of on the side there and you're
looking up clever Valley Road on this
applique site
and then this is looking down so this is
coming out of Montague Place coming
um looking to the left there next
so this is looking from a top window of
120 clovelly roads so this is primarily
the neighboring property of 119.
thanks
and then this is 120 degree valley roads
garden with the outbuilding that's
already on site
um kind of in the back of that photo
[Music]
and then this is looking towards 121 and
then obviously you can see the dwellings
of Montague Place there
so this is at the back of 120 Club
Valley Road just to show the change in
lands so as you come out this is looking
towards the garden of neighboring
property
and then this looking
um straight up for the kind of garden so
you do have to go upstairs to get to the
the top
and then this is looking towards the
neighboring um dwelling which is 121
um kind of from the back of the dwelling
itself
so this is just looking back towards 120
Club valley roads 120 is the the white
dwelling in the middle and then
obviously you've got 121 to the left and
then 119 to the right
this is standing on the the garden
itself so this is looking towards
Montague Place
um the fence obviously is about to meet
a high that you can obviously go up to
200 if they wish
so this is in the garden of 120
obviously looking at the Garden of 121
um and Montague Place then beyond that
so this is just further up to where um
roughly the the building will be
Associated
um which is being proposed
so this building is on site and
obviously this just gave reference which
I mentioned in the site visit yesterday
in terms of height so this um building
is 2.4 meters
um which was measured and then obviously
if it is any questions but on site visit
it was exposed they are going down 0.8
meters
um just to kind of get a guideline of of
the height
so this is um looking from the car park
to the West so the application site
um is well screened
um looking from the West kind of back
onto the rear Gardens of 120 Crivelli
roads
so this is from that car park kind of
looking down Montague Place
just to show the distance between
obviously Montague Place and the the
wall and then obviously 120 Cavalli road
is then set back further
so this is from Montague Place looking
up at the building
um of what you can see kind of directly
from it at the moment
and then this is just looking further
down
um Montague Place looking back towards
towards the building in that Garden
[Music]
this is just from the entrance of
Montague Place looking
um down the street
um and from this angle obviously the
building is um screened
so just going on to the proposed site
plan they are proposing uh new access
and parking to obviously alleviate the
parking on Clear Valley Road and then it
is a detached Annex
um so just to clarify that is why it was
advertised as a departure
um so it is two bedrooms it has been
designed for the intended occupier which
we have received justification as stated
in the report
these are the proposed elevations so the
main windows and doors are facing one
onto the shared Garden which will be
shared with 120 Valley Road and then the
window is facing towards um where the
car park is
and this is just the proposed floor plan
just to show in more detail of what
they're proposing
um so it's two bedrooms but then an open
sitting in kitchen and then a bathroom
so the main plan and considerations with
this application are the principle of
development the report goes into
justification behind it being detached
and not attached as per the policy the
impact on character and appearance
impact on residential amenities
objection comments were received for the
applications these have been discussed
within the report
highways Devon County highways did
detail that it should be dealt with
understanding advice
ecology other matters with regards to
Environmental Protection and therefore
the conclusion is to recommend
a resolution of approval thank you
thank you Sarah
um well there's just one contribution
which is a written effort to be read out
about the planning manager
and this is from Tim Hooper the
applicant
my name is Tim Hooper and I've lived at
120 clovelly road for the past 26 years
with my eldest son Andrew and my
disabled son Matthew for 15 of those
years my wife was Matthew's full-time
carer before she was diagnosed with
dementia in 2012 and was moved to ET
care home I then became the full-time
carer in 2011 Andrew's fiance Amy moved
into the property where she helps me out
with Matthew's daily meme Matthew finds
it difficult to walk on uneven surfaces
and even the stairs the annex will be on
one level with a ramp leading to the
front door for easy access the annexes
for me and Matthew to move into and then
Amy and Andrew can live in the main
property and that means they will still
be close enough to help with Matthew's
needs the annex will have a big enough
driveway so his daycare supporters can
drive straight up to the property and
drop him off right about mentor and with
ease turn around there has been many
incidents out on clovelly road where
Matthew becomes agitated and refuses to
get out of the car this will help
massively the annex will have a wet room
located close to Matthew's bedroom so
it's easy and safe to give him personal
care
thanks for listening
thank you Helen
right well that's um
that's the left latter of public
contributions canister Chris I think
councilor bushby and I are dual hatted
on this one right yeah
thank you
who would like to start the debate on
this I noticed really good Town Council
recommended approving Paris Evolution
thank you chair I suddenly a couple of
minor points but um maybe uh important
um on page 18 uh the Consulting
representations
and that says that result that the
applications approved on the provider
that the Alex has tied with this
existing properly in order that it can't
be sold as a separate dwelling
and the word soul is important now and
then over on page 20 third paragraph
done
um partly those paragraph says retained
cancer have requested that a condition
is attached to ensure the Arches Guide
to the whole dwelling and therefore
cannot be used
you know and also you play on words but
used in solder you know to obviously uh
different phrases there if it if it
cannot be used
I read that as if anything happened to
the existing you know the proposed
talent that building would be
effectively empty because no one else
could use it other than you know this
person now if you look at the conditions
condition for the text at the end of the
recommendation the accommodation here
back and making sure we use saw his nrx
ancillary to the existing dwelling known
as 120 cleverley Road sharing the access
parking and external amenity space at
that wedding and not as an independent
running
so it is it's ancillary 228
whoever's living in 820 stay in there
can use this as well
okay thank you
anybody else with any comments on it it
comes to Pennington thank you chair just
a couple of uh queries
um
by another is 0.8 of a meter drop down
on the ground level for the development
of the annex okay
um how are they going to get into
marketing place to get lorries there and
how can that be done with the agreement
of neighbors I know you've got a
condition in there about the working
hours but as the set of a molecule place
is you're going to be in a situation
where Laura you may call in and somebody
may want to get to work I wonder if it's
possible to put a condition there but
it's Laurie's come in with the agreement
of neighboring properties
yeah I don't think you can condition
that because they've got Helen and tell
me that I I'm counselor Pennington I I
think that would be very difficult to
enforce I think it would it would be a
reason to expect that that level of
arrangement there there is obviously
conditioned three recommended by the
Environmental Protection Officer which
restricts hours of construction work and
that includes deliveries
um one one would hope if there was any
any conflict with somebody needing to
get out that you would hope that people
would probably resolve that but I don't
feel it's something we could add in the
condition and my second point if I make
sure any lighting between the main house
and the sort of the Court Annex because
there is quite a distance between the
two
but I would assume it will be operated
as one property in theory is there any
need for safety lighting between the two
properties
so yeah I probably wouldn't say so
obviously the annex that's why they have
introduced obviously the
um access as it is because the main
intended occupier can't go up from the
stairs from into the garden so that's
why they've obviously one created the
access to alleviate kind of Highways but
also to give them safe access in there
and the path is
obviously I walked that path it is the
kind of a normal Garden Path
um it looks probably further than it is
on the site plan so I don't think there
would need to be any kind of external
lighting
um between the two
because they will be used as one yeah
Josh
you know we've been on planning a
long-time councilor Christie certainly
will remember that Montague Place that's
the hard part that was constructed there
that just Ellen's just passed
um used to be a piece of that Victorious
District Council on and we gave planning
permission for it to be made into
account oh I think the residents have
all contributed it in more place towards
that so
how it used to be there with traffic
well it used to be terrible in Montague
Place and obviously construction traffic
used there when they built and they had
to exclamation a great deal of the land
there to get down to that level for the
car park so I I honestly don't think for
this development
construction traffic is going to cause a
big problem
um but like with any side you've got to
be a bit patient when things are being
moved in and out of the develop also
well unless anybody else Mark Costner
Brown sorry
um it is against
dn25 yeah
um and although I have some sympathy
with the people that want to um building
on it
I do worry where we're going with this
why do we make policy if we're going to
go again something like that so I'm
gonna have to do something again about
voting for this chat
yeah my personal view is when this plan
was developed when the tourism was
getting planned was developed it made in
my view my personal Beauty made a
mistake by insisting on action card to
be attached
if it's crossed by there's no reason why
I shouldn't have it on it but that
that's just my personal view it is
against the current policy as you say
but of course material consideration
have to be taken into account with
applications and this is in my view and
I'm going to move approval of that that
um there are material considerations
that give us that
and for if we go against that models I'd
rather set them up please thank you
councilman
anybody else want to comment on this one
okay it's been moved to improved by my
I've moved it for approval cancer bushby
secondly can you take the vote please
that's a brown okay
that's the bushby or that's the Christy
oh that's a craigie or pencil 11. for
councilman golf or pencil Pennington
four
then six for the motion and one against
chair
um
thank you Sarah
all right we move on to our second
application this morning which is on
pages 24 to 36 of your agenda welcome
Transportation
nice to see you
and James Jackson will present this one
thanks Jim thank you chair good morning
everyone
okay as the chair said this is a
application reference one slash zero
eight oh one slash 2022 fql those
interaction away panels an office and
dog grooming salon and eight foot safety
fencing it's a resubmission of a former
application that was refused in May 22
under delegated powers uh it was refused
due to the proximity of the panels to
third-party dwellings and the subsequent
potential for significant armed
residential amenity uh from the sound of
dogs barking
the site is at West Villa in
chillsworthy and next time please okay
it's located in the countryside but it
is well related to the Village of chills
where the it's approximately 80 meters
from the chillsworthy development
boundary
this is the site location plan here
there's three the pink Park and
recycling which is shown in red the
northern part there is a proposed area
for the exercise area
and apparently the corner of the field
which is a grass field
and down in the
um that South Eastern parcel is the
kennel building which is currently a
vegetable patch which is used by the
applicants and not Western past all over
by the highway is opposed to the car
parking area again apparently a grass
area
existed in access to the public highway
is also over on on the western side
the blue blue line here obviously um
indicates the the extent of the
applicants ownership as well there
in the sacrifice corner of the Blue Line
you can see the applicants dwelling and
Annex and support agricultural buildings
which are known as poor state of repair
and also uh committee may remember the
existing mobile home which was
previously committed permitted by
committee which is shown now just
against the blue line on the certain
boundary there as well
um something that's not shown on this
plan is too recently constructed
detached dwellings where um you can
probably see there I think you haven't
where but whether it was better even on
there are two dwellings there now uh
they're not shown because it's uh simply
because they're recently constructed an
Ordinance survey data it's not been
updated but they are shown on
um on on plans within the submission
which I'll come into come on too shortly
um
there's other third-party dwellings as
well
um which are over to uh on the other
side of the public Highway over to the
to the west and also down to the the
site east of the sites as well
there's also some reason constructive
dwellers there which you can see which
are over to the east which is um which
is uh related to Colonel house
and then the main part of children
related to the neighborhood performance
over to the East and to the site as well
uh children is designated an ability in
the local plan
uh and excitement
it's just a couple of aerial images
showing what just described effectively
on the left-hand side we've got uh the
site there sort of as a close-up image
that Northern Star is the proposed
location for the dog exercise area the
and then the two seven star the Army
owes kennels location and also for the
car park and then on the right hand side
is just an aerial image there that just
shows precise relationship to old movie
within the wider context and again the
red star denotes the precise
next slide please
and suggest the existing site now which
just shows the existing uh situation on
the ground
next slide please and then we can see
the proposed site plan here also you can
see the two recently constructed
dwellings are shown
um on that site plan and the submission
annotates the distance and effectively
between the various parts of the
development and the third party
dwellings so we can see here that the um
the dwelling over to the West is shown
as 105 meters from the proposed exercise
area and 120 meters from the kennels the
new dwellings to the side they're shown
as 96.4 meters to the panels and the
other dwelling for the site that shows
102 meters separation between that and
the count
uh the dwellings over to the um east of
the exercise area there's obviously a
significant distance there as well
between the exploit area and those waves
uh also shown is the parking area that
shows uh provision for eight car parking
spaces with some Landscaping as well
um and it shows the kennels building as
well which is purpose built by a company
in Malvern
uh the kennels building would be imposed
by a fence and a hedge Bank on its
southern and western side and on its
northern and Eastern side we're being
closed by existing mature hedgerows
there's also a Subway and a septic tank
and a drainage fields to see all the
surface water and bow water
and uh the exercise area there is shown
up in the northern part that's 30 by 30
meter
um grass area and there is a suggestive
condition as well to put up to be
imposed by a coaching rail fence should
members be minded to to planning
permission
next slide please
on the left hand side here we have a
proposed kennels building eight panels
which would provide a maximum of 16 dogs
constructive constructed of a upvc frame
with glazing and poor safe mesh in terms
of its size it's approximately 12 by 10
meters in terms of its footprint and on
the right hand side that shows that
proposed building in the context of the
fencing and also the Hedge Banks they're
proposed so you can see from that that
drawing the the back to the top of the
building would be
um would be visible there but the
majority of it would be screened there's
another condition recommended as well in
terms of to ensure that those hatchbacks
covering all the candles buildings
brought into use that's just considered
prudent really in terms of the character
and appearance of the area
next slide please
this is the proposed floor plans that
shows that showed the layout of the
kennels building and as I said
previously is eight kennels which could
accommodate a maximum of 16 dogs and in
the bottom right hand corner there is
the office and the grooming area
um in the corner there
next slide please
uh just a few photographs here on the
left we have the proposed site for the
kennels as you can see that's currently
in use as a domestic vegetable patch
then on the right it look inside from
the kennels area so you can see the
African swelling on the right hand side
and it's Annex the mobile home that's
previously permitted by the committee
and an offense behind that and trees and
then beyond that are the two dwellers
that were recently constructed and over
on the left and also existing third
party dwellings as well
next slide please
uh this shows on the left the proposed
exercise area is just looking into that
exercise area from the north as you can
see it's corner of a field which is
currently a grass area and on the right
hand side this is looking East from the
um dog exercise area towards the
recently constructed dwellings at clear
no packs
next slide please
the left hand photograph shows composed
car parking area with the access
um beyond that and the right hand
photograph just shows the access there
which is looking into the site
uh next time please
and the material considerations in this
case are principle of development
character appearance highways
residential amenity biodiversity and
power and surface water drainage and set
out in your office's report officers do
consider the principle of development is
established and supported by policy pm14
which offers uh in principles for
support for small-scale economic
development when it's well related to
deploying settlements such as
chillsworthy and that is subject to
considerations relating to immunity
highways and character impact as I said
at the start don't under delegated
powers of previous application was
refused in May last year due to that
impact and now that is still a key
consideration for members to consider
today in terms of the impact of
third-party dwellings
um the there's obviously a number of
objections that have cited that as a
concern and that's understood
the Environmental Protection Officer has
been consulted in this club that it has
no objection to the proposals and that's
on the basis now of the increased
separation distances between the kennels
and the dog exercise area and to the
third party dwellings and also set out
within the offices report is the details
of the noise management plan which has
been submitted and that sort of goes
into significant decal really about
measures that will be
employed to
mitigate any noise impacts to an
acceptable level and that's in terms of
the building design itself which is uh
designed by a specialist company or
pedigree pens which are based in Malvern
and there's a condition
um there to require that to come forward
in terms of that specification of that
building
there's also other measures in terms of
no access to the kennels for any
visitors restrictions on Dropbox and
collection times between eight and eight
people can only arrive at the site by
appointment only and it can't just turn
up
there's in terms of the exercise area
only one dog or or two dogs from the
same family will be exercised at one
time to limit any noise there and also
there's within the design of the
building this sound absorbing ceiling
panels and also triple ventilation which
should ensure that windows don't have to
be open all the time if they do have to
be over then there's very small Windows
towards the top of the building
and as as sort of set out by an
Environmental Protection Officer really
that that management plan does set out
robust measures to to ensure that the
any harm would be restricted to
acceptable level through so
um
that has led to a recommendation really
that the application should be approved
on the basis that the uh and meet any
immunity harm can be controlled with
acceptable levels and that the
application is acceptable in all other
respects so it is recommended for
approval um subject to the conditions
set out on pages 34 and 35 every weekend
thank you
thank you James
write our first contribution is from
Robert Hall speaking against it uh
Parish counselor
and I'm not sure settled if you've got
three minutes to yeah thank you address
the committee thank you
well good morning Mr chairman thank you
for letting me address your committee
I'm speaking on behalf of polls for the
Emirates Parish Council and tools with
residents to oppose expanding
application West Fuller is described as
being on the outskirts of chills with
your village for recent planning
approvals through that for residential
property some of it outside the local
plan means that West building is now
founded by residential homes 12 recently
built an outline approval for a further
six
the committee report map is misleading
as it doesn't show all these properties
and it would have you believe the site
is more open than is the reality
although obviously James has shown you
and a more current map
Parish council's main concern is the
noise and light pollution the dog
kennels will inflict on residents who
will have literary course to address the
issues despite the noise studies carried
out no study will ever mitigate dogs
barking at Hope and run and their
disturbance to residents
in the committee report we know the
conditions attached to the recommended
approval however this would do nothing
to appease residents as they are aware
of those little capacity to check or
enforce the conditions the case in point
being a retrospective planning approval
given for a static caravan of less than
10 months ago where the conditions have
not been met this committee will also be
aware of the hundreds of enforcing
orders outstanding within porridge
light pollution is noted as a prime
consideration for any new development
how will this be regulated for a cannon
in the middle of a plot a 24-hour access
will be required it seems a conflicting
conundrum and impossible to regulate but
will be all too obvious to the
Residential Properties surrounding
Westfield
the planning application is supported by
a business plan it states in addition to
dog breeding they will now take mature
dogs who have their capacity to increase
the noise generated especially excited
panels in a strange environment who's
going to regulate that only two dogs
will be allowed in the free running area
at any one time or one actual storage
State when this condition is broken
the committee report makes so to the
business opportunity to the area but the
business is already up and running the
business plan makes no provisional for
local employment opportunity and as
there is none this is Computing planning
statement
the first planning application for these
kennels was has been refused in this
application the reciting of the cans
within the Block it's merely smoke and
mirrors that the Residential Properties
will be subject to the same noise and
light pollution
clearly there was strong enough grounds
through enthusia prevention and nothing
has changed with this application other
than to make it more objectionable with
mature dogs on site and the potential of
an animal crematorium
please acknowledge the loss of quality
of life that we replace on residents
adjacent to west villa and to whom will
have little sorry rumor have to live
with an unacceptable business growth
that has no right to be in a village
setting to requested to refuse this
application thank you
thank you very much
our next speaker is in support of the
application Ben Harris who's the African
if you'd like to come up speak right
into the end of that moment picture
and once you settle you've got the
emails to address the committee as well
thank you for somebody thank you
okay so currently we are a five-star
licensed business
um licensed by toriage Council for uh
breeding and we're simply wanting to
upgrade our facilities to improve the
welfare and efficiency within the
business
um these are fire specification kellogs
to create a home atmosphere similar to a
conservatory constructed review PVC
double glazing and high quality
soundproofing
at the moment
um the dogs are located at the main
house so to put the kennels in they
would actually be further away to any
other dwellings that that are close to
the area
um in six years of running the business
at the address you've never had a
complaint in person or via the council
and all our immediate neighbors have
stated in their objections how wonderful
and tranquil The Village actually is but
the business is already running
um so we know we're not causing that
much of a nuisance as it is
um yeah and they're just concerned with
what noise a kennel business might bring
to the area but in fact we've been
running the business there for six years
um and it's it's only a small amount of
residents that have objected
and and we're outside of the development
area for chillsworthy as well so we're
not actually in the village and we're
just simply looking to upgrade the
facilities to make the business better
thank you
thank you Mr Harris
I'm finally to address the committee is
Ward member Kevin
foreign
thank you chair and um
I call this planning application in
and I stand before you as Ward member
for Milton
within which um Childersburg is located
um my stated reasons for calling this
application remain valid and these are
set out in the office's report
um
I think uh James did has modified the
plan that was attached to the front
piece of the
officer's report but
it it still doesn't show that is it
possible that I can illustrate on the
plan on the swing
in
which that one no
no that one is it better if I use that
so the committee members can see it or
that one so that
well
they should see the same yeah
um so
we have
um here the two nude Bunnings
um what is long shown
that members you can see it's probably
better yeah
so James has indicated that um this is
now
um planning content was granted on West
Riverland for some unknown reason that
does not appear in the relevant history
uh why I don't know
um but the relevant history the site has
a relevant history a long relevant
history and these two dwellings and do
not figure in that
but this area here this is a new house
spray side
this area here also has planning consent
for six dwellings and the whole that
section there makes up the six twenties
so this area
links through so West Villa is not in
the countryside West Villa is the
Western end of Children's Village
and I you know this is fundamental that
is not divorced
so
in in regards to the principle of
development the fundamental question
here is West Villa in Countryside
location or is it now Integrity part of
Children's Village
my view is that because of the two new
dwellings that have been built on land
that was part of West fellow and the um
allocation of housing on land between
West Park and the new house Braeside
recently constructed to the Western
meadowside West Villa is now linked
directly to and forms western boundary
of the built environment that is the
rural Village of chillsbury
it's been noted by committee members at
the site plan will have done all that
um effectively therefore West Villa is
an integral part of Children's Village
this is such a fundamental planning
issue that I feel it necessary to bring
into the committee's attention and
extract from the applicant's application
in 2018 for the two dwellings
where the applicant's agents GM planning
stayed in their Planet planning
statement that guidance within paragraph
55 of the npps and I quote
goes on to suggest that isolated homes
in the Countryside should be avoided the
proposed development cannot be said to
be isolated as it is proposed to be
cited within the village
surrounded by other housing they go on
to State my clients land at West Villa
is a long established part of the
village visually and physically and is
surrounded by two dwellings on two sides
the site is therefore considered to be
within the village and a subject policy
dbt2
it would appear now that the success of
this current application relies on the
complete opposite argument
st07 relates to spatial development
strategy in the countryside Beyond
Villages
st11 states that the proposals for
economic development would be supported
where they do not conflict with other
local planned policies well surely ndo
ndtlp includes policies designed to
protect development in inappropriate
locations and in particular protect
rural organic settlements
and amenities
dm14 provides in principle support for
small-scale economic development in the
countryside
the key question here is whether the
site really is in a Countryside location
and Beyond The Village of chillsworthy
because if as I believe to be the case
it is now properly within not now
properly within a Countryside location
then planning to call us is st07 sd-11
and dn14 are not applicable and
therefore the application should be
refused
um I would just say here I am going a
little bit longer than I should want to
do but this is linked to the next
application and I won't repeat myself
um on the question of character and
appearance the issue here is not so much
to do with appearance as a significant
adverse effect the development would
have on the character of the area the
peaceful and tranquil rural Village
environment which I'm sure is the very
reason why the very vast majority of
children residents chose to live here in
first place
um I did a brief search of existing
commercial dog kennels in the devil area
and these were in excess of 40 and all
of these the ones I looked at all
appeared to be in a remote rural or Farm
location and well away from established
Villages or residential amenities
and in terms of residential immunity as
the officers report States right at the
beginning of the support policy dm01 of
the
ndtlp confirms that development will be
supported where it would not harm the
immunity neighboring properties
with proposed commercial dog kennels
located within less than 100 yards of
papering properties I would argue that
it cannot fail to have a harmful effect
on the amenities of these neighboring
properties
it must be appreciated that noise and
dogs here would not come just from the
kennels and exercise area but more
likely each time dogs are delivered to
and collected from the site which would
be out in the open
and without any acoustically controlled
built to Kennels
I'm afraid I just cannot accept the
findings of the applicants instructed
sound experts and I'm surprised that the
Victoria's District Council
Environmental Protection Officer has
concluded that any resultant and I quote
any resultant harm to Residential
Properties immediately would not be
significant
I know for a fact that the residents of
neighboring properties vehemently
disagree and even the threat of
commercial dog kennels being located so
close to their properties is already
causing them severe stress and anxiety
um
all of you sitting on this committee
represent the well-being of residents
within your own Ward and I would urge
you to consider how you would view such
a development proposal so close to
Residential Properties in your own Ward
I on behalf of the number of children
residents say that they've considered if
consented the proposed development would
have a significant adverse impact on the
immunities currently enjoyed by the
residents of neighboring properties and
new offers to be built and consequently
constitute dmo1
conclusion the reasons I've given I
can't agree with the case officer when
he states that the principle of
development is considered acceptable
that was a quote nor with this statement
that the residing of the kennels and
exercise area from where they were when
the last application was refused would
ensure that residential immunity within
this area will be adequately
safeguarding
on behalf of concerned local nearby
residents and the new residents of
houses yet to be built I would say that
the principle of the proposed
development here is not acceptable in
this Village location and that the
proposed reciting of the kennels and
exercise yard will not in any way
Safeguard local residential immunity
in his conclusion the case officer
noticed that no noise-related complaints
have been received in respect to the
existing dog breeding business at the
site but please note that there is a
huge difference between us between small
business where apparently two dogs are
used breeding and housed in a house that
is West villain to a commercial business
with outdoor kennels for 16 up to 16
boarding dogs together with outdoor
exercise in it
fundamentally though it is my contention
that this site is not now legitimately
in a Countryside location but
realistically it is in a village
location
this view hasn't been even been endorsed
by the applicant's own planning
consultants in this statement relating
to application one forward slash 0680 in
2018. consequently I would request that
this application be refused as it is
contrary to policies st07 st11 dm01 and
dm14 of the ndtlp
thank you thank you
before and brought counselor Hamilton I
uh made a mistake thank you Adam to
pointing that out we've got a speaker
from the public against this application
I don't know I missed that it's on my
list Richard Allen Smith
thank you I'm sorry sorry I should have
gone out to the order we know but if
you'd like to get second again speak
right into the end of that moment
picture voice and once you said I told
you for three minutes you address the
committee defense thank you for having
me
in here yes
my main objection I absolutely agree
with everything that counselor happel
said and I would appreciate
taking a firm note of that
my main objection is that it will create
noise pollution but noise pollution of a
very particular and penetrating kind
stressed dogs in company with others can
both whine and bark and howl and Yelp
and underarming 115 decibels this may be
heard up to 500 meters away the nearest
houses are
they say 96 meters
chillsworthy is a quiet residential
religion with many more houses than are
shown on the application of that and
they will be affected we will be
affected I live closest to them
I must say also that the two houses
recently constructed were granted
permission and build
by these same applicants that needs to
be clear
this is a resubmission of a previous
application which was refused due to its
impact on amenities but little has
changed they are still dogs which will
create an unacceptable adverse effect
being Within earshot it is said that
only two dogs at a time are to be
exercised but how is that to be enforced
failures to enforce our Legion now I
quote directly from the delegated report
the Environmental Protection Officer
concludes that any resultant harm to
residential immunity would not be
significant he continues it is pertinent
to note that dmo1 refers to significant
harm as opposed to just harm
so there you have it
causing harm is acceptable is it
don't cause harm
please refuse this application thank you
thank you
right that that is the end of speakers
to this application so uh it would like
to start the ball rolling council at
Princeton well yeah I wouldn't wish
barking dogs on anyone because I I go
back to
um the problem we had a welcome I don't
know if you any other recall it where
that kind of the kennels there are a
long way from anywhere and yet we were
inundated with complaints across a
valley the noise but I have a problem
with this one because I see the proposal
when I saw it first it said erection of
eight candles and I'm hearing this along
and I thought oh they would stay in
there why they get groomed
um
I then read what
holsworthy hamlets said their Parish
Council councilors were informed this
application concerns an existing dog
breeding business the applicants would
like to relocate to a different position
which is more Central within their
property
rather than the creation of a new
business EG the boarding kennel business
as apparently some people have assumed
and when you read the actual application
nothing here about boarding kennels is
this a boarding business or
nowhere are they applying for a boarding
kennels it just says kennels
um it's very vague and holes are the
habits don't think it is a boarding
camps can you try and sort that out for
me yes certainly chasing thank you yeah
it would be boarding cattles because
that's that's the neat the nature of
business that they actually currently
run is is basically a dog breeding
business and they also do ancillary
um
and scenery activities related to that
such as microchipping as well and they
also do carry out of some small um scale
dog grooming as well so this they do go
hand in hand because the the kennels
obviously is related to dogs
etc etc but the the kennels will be
aboarding kennels facility there's not
where the kennels are used particularly
in conjunction with dog breeding
necessarily because it's because it will
be private clients that can obviously
employ use those services and board
their dogs Within These candles so why
doesn't implications say is a dog
boarding business it doesn't say that
well I think it does say that it's
obviously in panels so yeah
well I I just thought it would be
implied by the panels that it would be a
boarding business rather because they
think about the nature of dog reading
then you don't necessarily need
um kennels for the dog breeding
exclusively would you I would have
thought
I don't know I don't really build
all right I think as well chat can I can
I clarify the planning position in terms
of the countryside aspect I think it's
quite important to come back to that
um obviously the ward members sort of
set out its position in terms of the
built form as as coming towards that
site by virtue of the creative
um or the construction of two dwellings
and now it doesn't consider that this is
a Countryside location
in in planning terms it is a matter of
fact that this is that this site is in
the countryside it's outside of the
development Factory it may be in the
future in terms of a local plan review
or something like that with the
development would be redrawn to take
into account
um uh recently constructed development
into those two loans but as we start now
the the site is in the countryside
basically outside of the development
boundary for
um for chills lately and so and so that
that obviously does influence the policy
context in terms of st07 being a
Countryside location
um and also the M14 in terms of being
within the rural area and supporting
local small scale Economic Development
and I think the other policy point just
to point out is that as Mr energy points
out one of the speakers is that policy
dmo1 which seeks to protect residential
immunity
does refer to significant harm rather
than just harm so that that really is
the test of whether that impact would be
acceptable or not is whether that
reaches the bar of significance or not
and so from an opposite point of view
that that well has not been reached to
say the proposal does does accord with
the mo1 but that is really the key
inspiration I think I didn't say when it
finished the presentation but the
millership is here the Environmental
Protection Officer and I think if the
service did have any queries about the
the noise impact from a more technical
perspective then he's obviously
available to answer any questions that
you may have as well
thank you James
well when I I mean
councilor Pennington thank you very much
chair uh go back to the Lord the noise
is obviously the issue here of the
contention
um I I I've been aware of dog kennels
and various parts of our own uh the
urban areas of bideford and that's how
it's called problems in the past
I want to ask a question about
the refused application
10296 was refused on the 17th of May
2022.
and yet sewed Acoustics on page 35
and condition seven actually accrued a
situation on the 28th of February which
is three months earlier
now then they're approving something
that Torrance is refusing is that
correct it was it two is it tolerance
environmental officer that's raising the
bar here or is this certain Acoustics
accomplished selling the equipment and
then trying to prove
um that the equipment will keep sewn
down can can it explain to me why these
dates don't quite tie up yeah of course
actually yeah no problem so sanguard
Acoustics are the
um noise Consultants employed by the
applicants basically and they've had the
first application after this annoys
um a noise assessment and also a noise
management plan basically on that date
on the 28th of back the issue with the
first application was although we did
have the noise management plan the
kennels and the Ecto exercise area were
considered far too close to existing
dwellings and so the noise management
plan wouldn't have actually mitigated
that harm because because of the
proximity basically so now that that the
kennels and the dog exercise area have
been moved to locations after proposed
as I showed here and so now we're in the
view of the environment Protection
Officer those those actual measures set
out in the management plan will be
sufficient because of the distance
involved
but my concern
chair
um uh James uh is is the situation that
is our environmental officer team that
is setting the bar for the safety of
neighboring residents and not the
consultant Acoustics company appointed
to do the situation they do have a
concern here on that one so I that it
does Rachel me in a bit with that
difficulty
the second question as I may just go on
the prickly chair is that on page 26
and certain scientific located
um on the blood plane and Zone one
is so long high risk or low risk you
know so the same one is the low stress
it's the lowest yes it's slightly
different than what you said on page 33.
I mean it's apology because we do put
stones in there at all um there's no
zoning there at all so I say yeah okay
yeah yeah I think very much indeed on in
terms of first point sharing okay so
would it be useful to um to explain some
of his position in terms of the noise
impact at this stage yeah because it's
okay I'm hoping that uh committee
members have looked at the noise
assessment look forward
Acoustics it's a very very comprehensive
document I read it through yesterday
afternoon and I've printed off a couple
of extra
thank you thank you
is there a specific question
I mean looking at the objections it is
down to what kind of noise will be
generated from the site with the dogs
that are being exercised uh or in the
kennels looking at the location which
James has just said have been moved from
the original application to these
locations and the hedging around and the
other issues the kennels themselves have
got a very high level of sound
attenuation built into them
the main issue is does it satisfactorily
address the concerns of the nearest
residents and you've got measurements
that printed it off here you've got
measurements of the nearest properties
there and they're referred to by
soundgard Acoustics as well in fact I
think they've done that with those
measurements
so any questions specifically to do with
that
um because the noise if there is noise
of dogs will be intermittent
what's the legal position on that
because I've always understood it it's
where noise is fairly continuous that
people can put in an official Complaint
we have to do something about it if it's
intermittent like this because obviously
the number of dogs will vary
um you know all sorts of things
if somebody complained would that have
any official weight or
yes you're going under environmental
legislation
um irrespective of it being intermittent
or continuous we could still investigate
that as always nuisance absolutely it
wouldn't have to be it wouldn't have to
be intermittent to
um
they wouldn't have to be continuous
rather for us to substantiate or Justify
um investigating equipment
I only ask because I've had a complaint
where I think Torres have been out and
the noise never actually happened when
Torrid goes uh it's a real Catch-22
right but yeah I mean certainly for
statutory nuisance it's it's not just a
level of noise it's the frequency
generation so you know you're absolutely
right officers would need to witness
um the noising question
um in the determine whether it's natural
use and exists
and
sound guard actually and looked at the
West
scenario
with the kettles and the exercise area
in their report they've looked at the
worst possible scenario to come up with
the recommendation at the end that I
printed off there
the application should not be refuse
planning for reasons of noise impact
once it's likely that barking noise will
be heard within the environment it's
important to consider that environmental
noise assessment is not a test of
inaudibility
and that and that context was part of
the assessment it's considered that a
dog barking in a rural environment is
not out of context in that environment
especially the dents are already present
at the same and I'm just minded of the
dog's trust kennels out at Western and
they haven't been out there to the rules
you never hear any dogs to have barking
and then if kennels are properly
constructed and looking at this how it's
proposed to be developed in my view uh I
don't think there there is a problem
dogs don't bark all the time I mean you
walk to the barrels any day there are a
lot of people exercise adults there
they're not all barking and yapping
women very very rarely hear a dog
barking on them so
to have this picture in Mom's mind that
dogs are barking all the time
and look the kennels are eight candles
good could take 16. but you couldn't put
two strange dogs together normally in a
kennel so most of them when it is
similar occupancy most of the time I
would imagine that
this question said Mr military remain
um yeah we've got a lovely glossy
document from Soundgarden or whoever
they are I don't know where should you
deliver some storage because then they
we representative residence here and we
need to be a clear precise view from
torridge
so then we don't get any legal chances
coming forward because if we put
something forward to yourselves we're
doing your rcd board member alluded to
the other 20 is being built just a
longer Frontier finally building that
you know from the knee that lane side as
I've seen on the plans there where's
Taurus's point from this because it's
lovely that the applicants has gone and
spent this money onto the
they're working for them we work above
the torrent so I just like to see our
side of things yeah that should be a
former base you know a same decision
that we're going to do today so I agree
with cancer penitent honestly it's not
trying to catch you out but I will
represent the other residency as well so
you don't have to go back to these
residents tell them exactly why we've
got this decision sorry Castle can I
just to clarify so you were asking about
the validity of this particular acoustic
consultant sound guards is is that just
how to understand properly I don't want
anything to do with sound guys okay
our point exactly is to say 16 Candles
going forward 16 logs
how have you come to your decision on
the noise levels and what's the
mitigation you've come to to you know
you bet for pressures of the residence
today yeah well as I'm sure you and
other members of um within the document
that there's no
there's no standard for for measuring
um noise from dog barking there's just
no standard out there at this moment in
time so
you you have to look at other standards
and guidance who reach a conclusion or
um you know full form an opinion
and certainly the guidance and standards
that have been used within this noise
report this noise assessment
um we would certainly compare with
um I think with regards it's worth
mentioning with regards to the actual
acoustic consultant in this respect
they've got a wealth of knowledge and
experience and we've actually dealt with
them on another dog kennels sites so we
have a great deal of confidence in
what's been put forward here in this
noise assessment
okay
yeah you're based on
at the moment I I plan to make a member
we're just going by exactly what sound
do I tell us if you if you're telling me
this sure I don't know utmost respect
for you I I've noticed anyway I'm not
trying to demean yourself no no it just
where's Taurus's view honestly and
where's our paperwork which actually
backs us up yeah yeah so it just it just
takes a bit of if I was living I have
nothing to Economic Development yeah I'm
all for it and he cannot drive the area
room so I'm a full supporters I
supported E I think turning from the old
um was it that's Caravan I think what
said as well at the time I'm all forward
they're on the lands you should have
that right about living over there and
then upgrade it I'm on definitely yeah
the last time but this one there the
main issues of noise and yes how do you
make it and mitigate this noise how does
tolerance get this noise you can't just
say unless you have you know oh it
doesn't
so it comes to this criteria where you
could we have no report from Torres
councilman mcgough just just one minute
Gorge the the advice is is he I don't
know if you've looked at soundgard's
report and read it shared this is yeah
I'm not listening
Authority just let me it's orange just
let me no I don't want to let you go I
don't know you know what I'm chair in
this meeting so if your chair because
let me tell you
listen to me I'm not interested in
saying God's thing you get me interested
very disrupted please just let me say
you've heard the review of our
environment mental officer
potential noise and that's what we're
talking about potential noise
from not from dogs on the site if you've
looked at the layout of the site and
where the kennels and where they don't
exercise area will be and the conditions
that are in the recommendation to prove
it if you've read all that
we've got to make our decision on what's
before us
part of the evidence brought forward is
this comprehensive report that I read
through about possible
what the issues may be and as I said
soundgard themselves looked at the worst
case scenario when they were judging the
possible if you read about the
construction of the kennel and that's
built and the noise attenuation that's
built into that all that is in
documents that were online that people
can read so we've just got to look at
and yeah most people in the area the
ones in the nearest properties you've
got the measurements of the distances
which I think are quite long distances
in most respects the talk of the six
dwellings that may get built that have
got planning to be they might not be
built that's nothing to do with this to
be honest whether they're building up
nothing to do with this application
you've got to look at what's before us
it was turned down under officer
delegation before because of the
location of the proposed candles and
exercise area
now it's been moved and this is what's
before us and that's what we look at and
you can't just dismiss evidence that
either an applicant or an objector puts
forward said I don't do anything to do
with sound guy you cannot
that's two cavalierian attitude for
somebody on the plans committee you've
got to consider what's impossible and
what's been put forward by supporters
and objectives
sorry
thank you
um I didn't realize this is a crystal
ever show not the Taurus is Chicago show
but there you go
um go go back on the point which I will
address straight into you guys however
as a chair of plans I asked for torres's
Report with the touristy application
comes through it's always you have to do
no judicious so right any mitigation
from our own experts here we're just
happy people live expertly going forward
this is where my concern is remembers
but I'm trying to get clarity from the
members of the public right I'm going to
be in here if I could just come in there
and cancel explained
um the application supported by a
technical document which as you rightly
point out cancer has been prepared on
behalf of the app and Mr military is
um a statutory consultee in the process
so uh as a planning team as development
management officers we are not experts
in um
noise knowing the technical side of
noise so
um Mr military was consulted and you'll
see on pages 28 and 29 of your reports
there are
um
um the first very detailed
and then two subsequent responses now
from a storage planning point of view
that is the information we get from our
statutory console team which comments on
the technical information provided there
isn't a detailed noise report that that
Mr military would have carried out his
role is to appraise what is submitted
and
um advise us as the planning team
firstly whether the methodology is
accurate whether the assumptions are
accurate and whether whether he is a
professional Environmental Protection
Officer is Satisfied by it so I would
say in terms of the comments and the
petition put forward it is as you see on
pages 28 and 29 but of course if the
military can provide any further
clarification today
thank you Helen
councilor Christie yeah um just want to
bring up a couple of points that you
actually said
um the first one dogs don't bark all the
time I have one in my world the bloke
left at our boss day the dog started
barking and he stopped when he came back
half past five in the night I went
around him just listened to it you could
go around any time of day and the dog
was howling but that sound guard report
I'm glad councilman Goff brought it up
because the last
but you wrote out it was fascinating it
said that you should expect to hear dogs
in the countryside basically this is a
country
that argument was brought up with Corky
the Copper at the Heartland but didn't
break didn't account for anything there
did it
right anybody
sorry yeah
just briefly charity um on page 27 this
it says it understood that a license was
required from parishes and Council for
the proposed candidates
um I understand that
um but under what circumstances would
the license could the license be revoked
presumably it would be noise based
complaints
and the reason I say that is because you
mentioned just neighbors no standard to
measure dog barking noise which I find
like
it's range
say for the purpose of this assessment
that there's certainly no standards
um in the standard that has been applied
in this scenario
has been approved by ourselves with
regard to a question on life it's I'm
not a nice Microsoft but I believe
welfare and and issues such as stock
market nuisance
um
I think Warrington the license being the
boat okay
I mean there are
I think the license refers to the guilt
being in part of the of the business
that boiling candles I think two do need
license now we do monitor boarding
candles I know that there's something
I'm not going to be Brewing them again
they do get them on it they're inspected
every 12 months to see the complain the
Health and Welfare and all the rest of
it
so as I say
um
[Music]
uh I'm gonna propose it here we go with
the recommendation to grow because I
think
what's been laid out where the site in
the middle that you see on the screen
now and the Hedge rules to be
constructed
I I think the mitigation
will delay any figures or shouldn't they
any fears and I think
the applicant said he's been operating
for six years there now they've not had
any complaints from his dog breeding
business I don't know whether that is
any different to what's proposed as I
said there are eight candles you won't
necessarily have 16 notes there and I
think from what James said
um
nine as I read it the dog exerciser here
about the meeting
shall be used by no more than two adults
if any time then you said
a single dog or two from the same family
which is a bit different
so is that that's an amendment tonight
a single dog being exercised or two dogs
from the same family
so if you get too strange then there
could be more of an issue of noise would
there be an extra time
yes so I'll take one chat yes yeah so
that's an amendments you know to that
effect okay
um
and you'll remember we did approve a dog
exercise area down at Western Hall where
you're going to the boroughs of the
apricot cave and I've seen that being
used by that but I've never seemed to
hear dogs yapping and barking
usually the only ball can cause your
nuisance it's a frightened on word or
You Don't Know Me Anymore Bob and I said
you went to the dogs trust Council
there's a lot of don't say it then you
never needed Old Market and you happen
so I think it's over
conservative residents I accept that you
know they've got valid reasons to be
concerned but I do think that what's
proposed is that should be acceptable
and that there will not be a problem
from noise from this development with
the Satan an attenuation that's in place
so I'm on the moves that we do approve
this as per the recommendation well
somebody said from them
in that
and if nobody wants to make any further
comments we'll go to the vote thank you
thank you Chad
okay four cancer Brown cancer bushby for
cancer Christie or Council craigie oh
pencil leather or that's them
that's the Pennington or
seven four and one abstention chair as
you sound good
[Music]
um
this is this is on pages but the 37 to
45 and the channel
thank you
thank you Chad
um
as required this is on the on the same
site at West Villa and chillsworthy
application references 1 0 953 2022 fql
and the proposal is uh changing you to
land to um super generous um citing a
shipping container to how
packed crematorium
next slide please
this is the site location plan shown
urged in red there's currently a grass
area which is located adjacent to the
applicant's existing access and existing
access existing out buildings which were
previously mentioned in Broad stated
repair
the applicants again ownership within
the blue line
um is shown there the dwelling and the
annex shown to the southern part existed
mobile home previously permitted by
Banks committee and again uh not shown
on on this particular plan to the site
of that mobile home and the two recently
um constructed dwellings which were
discussed on the previous application
and again other third-party dwellings we
have on the opposite side of the public
highway to the uh to the north west of
the site
and also dwellings to the side east of
the site again the main build pool of
chillsworthy is to the East and the
southeast uh children is designated as a
village in the local plan and in
planning terms
um the the site is located within the
countryside but well related to
um the village of chillsworthy
um I thought the benefit members it
might just be worth sort of taking you
through a bit about how the crematorium
would actually function really it's not
an application that we received number
four committee
um on a regular basis so uh the the
specific model that the app that is
housing is in our field pet 2200 which
is a specialist facility that's
constructed for exactly the purposes of
cremation it has two Chambers
um the first chamber is heated to uh
1450 degrees C and that effectively
um incinerates the the carcass of the
animal there is about a second chamber
when which Heats to 850 degrees C
minimum which deals with the gases from
the incinerated complemented animal
the there's also heating below that
those chambers to ensure that there's a
360 degree even heat within within the
crematorium
and for this particular model
um it can handle up to seven pets per
day and it's below the 50 kilo per hour
threshold for when an environmental
period would be required but it is still
regulated separately to the plumbing
system it's regulated by the animal and
plant health agency
uh there's three fuel options for it you
um which are either powered by diesel or
n gas or LPG in this instant the
applicants are composing to use diesel
which would be a tank in one end of the
shipping container and the incinerator
in the other the other end of the um
shipping container
so hopefully that's just useful for a
background in terms of how this the
development will work and function
uh next slide please
uh just a couple of aerial images this
uh shows on the left the the site that
close up and the site there is marked
with the red star and again on the right
hand side actually shows the
relationship of chills would be to hold
the living and again the site is shown
shown with their own style
thanks bye please
again we exist inside the plan which we
show the situation on the ground
next next slide please
and uh this is the prepared site plan so
on the left hand side is the wider site
on the right I'm just blown it up a
little bit so it may have to be a little
bit clearer but effectively you've got
the uh the proposed shipping container
which would house the incinerator which
is shown against the mature hedge bank
which forms the western boundary of the
applicant's land and then on the other
side of that boundary is the the public
Highway
uh also Landscaping surrounding the
chicken container
um as shown there it's noted also that
the car pumpkin area is shown on the
proposed site plan however there's not
it's not actually within the red line
um for the application
uh this means really that members can't
consider that that as part of the
application I know members have just
resolved the grant permission for the
kennels for which the car parking area
is shown however there's obviously no
certainty that that's implemented even
though we're going to grab permission
for the kennels they may not Implement
that and so there's no certainty that
that parking area would definitely come
forward that issue is addressed within
the um officers report there is a large
area close to the applicant's way which
would comfortably and your offices view
accommodate any traffic and parking
movements that are required as part of
the development because really obviously
as I said to start with the incinerator
can only handle seven packs per day the
the applicant is proposing obviously
that this would be an appointment only
so they have control really only the
amount of people that are coming to the
site
um and obviously that is in your
office's View barely um small scale
next slide please
this just shows the elevations of floor
plans
um yeah the footprint of the container
would be six meters by 2.4 meters with a
height to 2.8 meters and uh the top of
the flu would be uh four meters
next slide please
this is just details of the proposed
incinerator wholly contained within the
shipping container
suggested condition three actually
specifies this particular incinerator
um and in your opposite view that
condition is necessary to ensure that
the uh the impacts would be acceptable
next slide please
uh some photographs this is left looking
spank across the site from the access
the right hand side shows the site again
uh the shipping container would just be
cited to the right to the telegraph pole
as you can see there
next slide please
on the left hand side is the existing
parking area which is up by the um
Atkins dwelling
and on the right hand side the existing
access and uh and Gates
and there's some Victoria
representations of the incinerator shown
within um within the shipping container
next slide please
the material considerations in this case
are the principal of development
character and appearance highways
Resurrection amenity biodiversity and
surface water drainage
as previously it's your officers view
the policy of the M14 officers in
principal support for the application
um by virtue of its uh office support
small-scale economic development in the
rural area where it's well related to
defined settlements such as childworthy
um again the key key consideration for
members here is the impact on on
resolution amenity there have been a
number of objections as you've seen from
the officers report which do raise
concerns in terms of emissions again we
have Michael here if members do have any
specific queries in that regard
um because you'll see the Environmental
Protection Officer Matthew military has
confirmed that there's no objections and
subjects conditions that the incinerator
should be used in accordance with the
manufactured specification
um and again the really big concerns
over the parish council award member and
the members of public are are noted um
as set out though within the offices
report it is considered that the amenity
impacts would be acceptable and uh and
as all other matters are also considered
acceptable it is recommended that the
application be approved subject so the
condition is set out on page reported by
of your agenda thank you chair thank you
James
right we've got speakers to this one
this application
and and we've got this the parish
councilor again councilor Horace
that whole holes with a Hamlet
and again used three minutes to address
it thank you Mr chairman
uh speaking on behalf of hoges Parish
Council to post the change of use of
land that the operation of an animal
crematorium actor yesterday
my research shows in the operation of
animal Crematory is unregulated whatever
conditions are attached to approval the
owner has already shown contempt in not
complying with paying approval
conditions what is said and what will
become practice will not be regulated
who will oversee and ensure maintenance
of the Union is carried out and that it
will be operated in accordance with the
manufacturer's instructions
there was no mention within the
environmental report because the need to
recognize the carbon of footprint as a
committee you repeatedly approved
planning for solar Farmers to meet
government demands of clean energy and
environmental concerns then the planning
officer is minded to accept the
significant industrial carbon producing
unit operating in a residential location
how can you justify this Blood flopping
policy
Tuesday the residents will be alone by
this lack of environmental awareness but
we'll be prevailing wind will blow these
diesel fumes across adjacent properties
noting that the committee report map is
not accurate to affect the position the
12 year homes and the outline planning
approval for opponent of six properties
where this is considered totally
unattractive to any developer who will
not help tolerages housing command
while the supporting evidence of the
unit's operation meets environmental
standards it is still discharging diesel
combustion products that are harmful
particularly with lower emissions over
an extended period and the unit has no
exhaust cleaning capability
the planning environment reports states
there is no significant risk in the
plant operation but this also implies
that there is some risk that it's not
risk-free
many residents have commented on how
inappropriate to be breeding puppies
canoeing dogs and disposing of love pets
within the same site
this unethical business operation is not
suited to a residential location
the letters of support have no substance
and appear to be from people who helped
to prevented for as children in
residents have written in detail they're
real concerns such an operation
furthermore there is no mention of any
employment opportunity the research
shows there are alternatives that annual
promotion facilities within North
America
we do not dispute that the unit is
compliant but the business operation is
totally inappropriate in a village and
residential setting and strongly
requests that you refuses planning
application
give us a chance
uh next speaker speaking against the
application is Richard Ainsley again I
am
the business democracy
we do not cite
nuclear
dumps near people we do not have
shooting ranges near schools
in no circumstance should a pet
Crematory be situated in a quiet
residential Village cremation you should
properly take place far from where
people live their lives
contrary to what is claimed there is no
need to burn dead animals here
Mr godolphin in the village recently
lost the dog it will give me its
cremation was arranged quickly and
efficiently by local events and vote
this is an industrial application
inappropriate to the proposed site
it also contravenes the local plan in
that it should it would not be enabled
in quotes enabled to meet local economic
and social need
the vital but often ignored matter of
residential immunity is given short
Stripped by the Environmental Protection
Officer and others there will be
admissions smoke and odor released far
too close to our dwellings
the contents of which I am not satisfied
are safe
this is the latest in a series of
schemes in which you appear willing to
overlook the reasonable objections of
those who will be affected detrimentally
and directly
in the name of democracy
everyone was objecting to this all of
them other people
in the name of Justice please refuse
this
thank you
the next speaker is in support and
that's been a Hurricane
thank you
okay so from our research there's
definitely a need for a pet crematorium
in the area and we have uh five vet
practices one side willing to use the
service already based in holesworthy
Butte Brad worthy Heartland and
Torrington there isn't currently a
probationary service in toriage at all
our main customers should be directly
from the Vets so it shouldn't be too
many traffic movements in and out
um breeding dogs and pet cremation
actually go side by side potentially
dealing with the same customers under
different circumstances
and all over the country there are quite
a few kennels that have their own
crematorium so we know that the
businesses go hand in hand this is a
deaf or approved system with minor
emissions
it's placed inside the shipping
container for easy movement and
relocation if if needs be it won't be
visible from anywhere other than on our
own property and we've done lots and
lots of researchers spoken to many
animal businesses in the area and they
all feel that there is actually a need
for this service in the area and as seen
in the amount of support comments which
we've had from vets pet shops and other
various animal businesses it's certainly
a sustainable business because animals
need to be disposed of on a regular
basis
um and the thing is we've we have West
Villa it's not viable to run simply as
an agricultural holding because there
isn't enough land there
um and we feel that it is a necessary
proposal for the countryside and it's a
very viable proposition and Villages
need an economical driver and it's not
available anywhere else in storage
thank you
thank you
and
councilor has been speaking to this as
the board member
thank you chair
um this will be much briefer
um
obviously
the main substance of my argument
against this one to a large extent
um
is the same as before I I still maintain
this is a village location it's not in
the countryside it may be classified as
in the countryside in planning terms but
this is a village location
uh however
the proposal to cite an animal
crematorium in a village location is
totally unacceptable and as far as I'm
aware unprecedented in the UK human and
animal crematoria are with obvious good
reason always cited sensitively
discreetly and away from residential
areas Villages and the like
the planning process here in the UK
performs many functions but one of the
primary functions is to ensure that
inappropriate development does not take
place and this in my view is a prime
example of just that without a shadow of
doubt this if this development is
permitted it will cause significant harm
to the immunities of neighboring
properties and consequently would be
contrary to North government or a local
plan policy dmo1
the case office of states in his report
that quote the application successfully
demonstrates that the impact would not
be significant those are going to
comments I wholeheartedly disagree with
the statement and can see nothing in the
report that demonstrates this surely
citing a crematorium
animal or human in a village location
would cause stress anxiety and
significant harm to the amenities of
neighboring properties and to not
appreciate this displays a lack of
sensitivity and understanding that quite
frankly Beggars believe it
I ask that this is refused
thank you comes to happen
that's the last speaker on this
application
thank you chair
um
James early I don't know whether I
misheard him but when he's talking about
the uh the actual
um shipping container that the
incinerator is going to be situated
inside did I hear your accent the fuel
tank is also going to be in with the
incinerator yes that's correct that's
deemed safe to do that presumably yes he
is I mean there's obviously other
legislation that covers um the storage
of hazardous materials as well thank you
um the only other point is merely an
observation really I mean much has been
said about the sighting of a crematorium
um but I'm sure we're all aware of the
northern crematorium where nowadays we
all seem to visit that more and more
often
um and that's surrounded by residential
development in fact there's a brand new
development which has gone in
immediately beside it and there's over
200 houses in there so you know they're
not always they don't Countryside
thank you chemistorically cancer
questions uh yeah the um I've just been
checking out you the only other one in
North Devon who's actually on a farm
that'd be a sure well it's not near
anywhere but
um can I ask one thing I've been
chairman of Crematory and it's a
slightly technical point but we have to
spend half a million quid on putting in
equipment to remove Mercury
and teeth
um pets today all have microchips in
that has that been allowed for and it's
inside a
container
um
side of things
uh what's going to ask the other
question about the curb you later but
perhaps I better not ask that
they've got a creme related you know
you have right thank you
Pennington
I would like to ask what is the
definition of a pet
the reason I'm asking is that there's
more and more small
Gardens they've got a few chicken that
are classed as pets
the avian fluid has been decimating a
lot of the countryside from the business
owners is there any risks of something
being classed as a pet being brought to
this area and spreading disease around
the other areas
it's hurting your question as you can so
I think in terms of agency there's
obviously a number of measures that are
in place through decorative to control
and manage that outbreak and so and and
so the applicants would obviously have
to abide with that separate legislation
as well as as well as planning
legislation so there is no definition
then between what this class is an
agricultural animal
and a pet so you could somebody could
bring in their Petco
I I suppose so I mean in this instance
that uh the size and the scale and the
incinerator would preclude
um a cow for example being created but
but I take your point really where does
the line where is the line drawn between
yeah where is the is that a pet or is
that an agricultural animal I think if
it was if it was Kept For The on a
residential basis really for the
enjoyment of a family then it would
qualify as a pet yeah yeah
I I mean looking at the specification
for the pet 200
the door aperture is 750 by 550. I think
we're going to carry through that it's
not meant for Animals of a large size
like that that's obvious and the
internal Dimensions 1200 by 750 by 700
so
it is for dogs cats if you've got pet
checking here put a pet chicken may I
follow on share I don't want to get into
a conversating new chair whatsoever but
may I hold on
um situation again comes up is the risk
isn't it is it's going to be probably
that that's around the area it will just
send the animals here or is it going to
be direct from
um the original cells without any
interaction with the vet and any
communicable diseases that may not be
picked up haven't been through that so
is the vet involved in this process or
is the best not involved in the process
and they they it it's both really
because I understand that the a
proportion of the business whether the
applicant is going to be through um
through Veterinary work obviously in
there and those animals are supplied
through that but as I understand it
there is also the ability for
um private clients to to bring their
animals to
um to the facility for cremation as well
so there is an element of biodiversity
risk here
um
no I I don't know I mean I guess again I
don't know the
um procedure for if you're a pet dies
whether you do have to report that to a
to a vet or anything like that or
there's something that covers that in
terms of other legislation I'm not sure
counselor okay thank you
thank you chair thank you Council
Pennington
anybody else want to contribute
I asked on the site visit yesterday
facilities he said and that's expecting
children there's quite a lot of central
heating systems running on oil down
there because I don't think they got
Mains gas down there that's correct yeah
the African Australian is also powered
but by other means again
so when
and read in the description in here of
the f200 the rest of it it goes with it
online I'm assuming
um just talk about any emissions from it
I don't think what that says
there won't be any
problems with emissions from the gym
then there'll be some obviously but
it's it's what what it is that's
important
I'd like the opposery approve this
application
and my friends are we just need to then
I don't see them says whatsoever
especially 48 the crematorium in
basketball how close it is it's not
going to be done on a large scale and I
think it's about events having the best
Lexi you know you've seen a little
openly in the market go for it is there
any way you can either increase the
business so it's economic drive for me
and really economics right
Etc fantastic because you don't want to
give them money to the middle man go
straight direct if you're going to do it
for private people like myself because
that's I'd love to come to you you know
I've got no pets so you know there's no
business transaction here there's
nothing back with all this or server but
you know gotta direct with you you know
fine you know I think that's actually
you're not doing like seven thousand a
day I'm pretty sure bonfires in people's
garden and said put a lot more rubbish
on them in a robots and urban as well
thanks Mr chairman thank you councilman
well I'm second that recommendation
and if everybody's finished contributing
we'll
go through little castle McAfee
recommended and I approval that I've
said in the picture thank you hence the
bank here
thanks to Brown councilor bushby that's
the Christie or Bachelor craigie or
councilor leather or text them a girl or
that's the Pennington or that's
unanimous chair
difference
in fact we move on then
gender items eight on me it's on pages
46 to 57 and that is the appeal
decisions
anything
that's pretty good day
[Music]
item nine on the agenda's costs on the
bills there are no costs been awarded on
the appeals that's on pages 58-59
imagine 10 on the agenda are the
delegated agmb applications Pages 60 to
61.
and you'll see there's only three of
them are been refused
those who noted that
and on page 62 to 73
is the list of
planning decisions between the 18th of
November 2022 and the 3rd of January
2023
and they're on pages 6 to June to 73.
all noted thank you
right actually
sorry I don't know I'm actually going to
explain so many reviews
there's one or two of the whole thing
right
that concludes the meeting for today
then that's the final item on the agenda
there's no part to himself I declare the
meeting for all the steps
thank you everyone thanks to everybody
honestly with you for your involvement
thank you to the office
members of the public who and listen to
it and Chandler University again